what have we learned from jk rowling
this year
ah wow well um
who ever thought that the creator of
harry potter would become
goebbels uh i mean
the most unforgivable
cancelled person it's extraordinary i
never thought that the harry potter or i
mean i never thought that the people who
are great fans of jk rowling would
would turn on her this much
the only thing i i've ever seen that i
can think of that it reminds me of was
i once saw some footage from trafalgar
square of some young girls who had
stayed out all night
waiting for leonardo dicaprio to come
for the
premiere of a movie and it was raining
and he didn't
stay very long to greet them because it
was raining and i remember
this footage of him i hate him
and they'd turned from
so devoted so devoted
they had camped out and arranged their
lives around
the possibility of a glimpse and got to
i hate him he's the nastiest man in the
world in no time
and that seems to be what's happening
with jk rowling um now of course not
with all her fans i don't i don't
over emphasize it but you know
there is a portion of people who believe
that the harry potter woman who they
relied on all the time when they were
growing up and who gave them
all this you know great time uh has
become
a nazi when they weren't looking and
i don't i should stress i don't think
she has
but there's a lot to learn firstly in
the
dementing tones of the time second in
the way in which
public figures can just be made
versions of them that have no
resemblance to what they are become
you know played out there in the public
sphere
and then you get the very interesting
other lessons i i don't like this term
cancel
culture i think it's sort of it's
already stale and it's not quite
accurate because
you know jk running hasn't been
cancelled or anything like that you know
there's a bunch of very insane people
who
think that the ichabog is too difficult
for them
to cope with in this life and by the way
i mean
because that's that was the attempt the
war of the attempted walk out at her
publishers hashed
was was not uh because they didn't
the the the i think 150 or so people
mainly young
at hachette who said they couldn't work
on the latest jk rowling book and didn't
want to be in the same
places they weren't publishing jk
rowling's big
book of trans it wasn't
chicks with dicks by j.k rowling
dumbledore and harry have an x-rated
adventure it wasn't that
no it wasn't that it was a new
children's book to be called the ichabog
and if you are an adult in the world
and you can't be in the proximity of a
children's book called the ichabog
it's possible this world isn't going to
be able to be arranged around you
anymore
you know it's it's that's that's that's
a bad
place to be and so
jk rowling's story has lots of things to
tell us but one of them is
what can be done by one person just one
person
second thing is we are learning lessons
about who can be counseled who cannot
and the fact
that clearly it matters
that she makes money and that she has
money
now that's not all a good sign because
it means that those of us who aren't
multi-zillionaires
are still vulnerable and i wouldn't like
to be in a position where only the very
rich can survive
attempted cancellation um
[Music]
but it shows that one person with a
voice
and with some guts she certainly has
that can say look
i'm not persecuting anyone i'm just
telling you
i'm not going along with the following
crazy thing you made up yesterday
and i admire her for doing that you know
she had no she didn't have to get into
any of this
she could quite easily have you know
continued buying you know
harry potter castle sized houses and
living very happily
most people most people will be very
happy to have a quiet life
and um and enjoy their their their their
loot
uh but she uh she she's done this and
and i have all
all respect for her for doing so it's
the sort of thing
her legacy in whatever form that will be
i'm sure that she is going to be
remembered you know harry potter is one
of the most
popular children series ever and and
really sort of was a pivot as well with
regards to
um children's literature i think that
was adult friendly as well you know like
you had kids
they even did special adult um cover
versions yes i know that was less less
embarrassed reading
i thought very poorly of the adult i
read the children's editions i thought
very poorly of the adults who
who thought they were fooling everyone
by reading still harry potter
yeah um but yeah and you're right she
could have just
quietly allowed that legacy to roll
forward without doing anything to
potentially upset the balance but she
decided not to
yeah yeah and i i i just think that we
need to reflect more on when things go
well you know you hear an awful lot
about you know when things are going
badly
this has gone very well you know um
there was a fear around the time of the
jk writing thing
that maybe even making money for a
company didn't protect you
you know that look at netflix netflix
has been willing
to to take financial hits in order to do
worse
programs so long as they're in the right
political realm um
i worried in the publishing industry
that would be the case with jk rowling
but but
but fortunately not um
fortunately it's still you know success
still speaks and i'm i'm delighted by
the people by the way i don't have been
snotty about this but
some of the people who resigned there
were some people who resigned from her
literary agency
because the literary agent was now
representing an anti-trans
person and i just it was
one of the funniest reads of the year
reading
the authors who'd resigned from jk
rowling's literary agency i
i can tell you her literary agent isn't
any poorer
i'll just i'll put it at its most
diplomatic the literary agents praying
to the gods thanking them that they
finally rid themselves of some
non-selling authors yeah yeah so um
so no but it's been it's been a very
it's been a very good thing because i
think we might have spoken about this
when we last spoke but
you know i i've always said that uh
cowardice is catching
and when a society sort of encourages
people to be sort of cowardly and meek
and shut up and all that sort of thing
and if the public figures all do that
then other people do it
but the reverse is also true and if you
know mainstream and totally responsible
and respected figures like jk rowling
uh do do this and fantastic more
more more men and women will say what
they think
and they won't go along with stuff just
because they're told they have to
particularly it's mad stuff that was
just made up yesterday